闇な
ハンズ目社長だよみんなもうすげっ
受験の季節だねみんなちゃんと
勉強してるかな
pa
難しよっこちら始めた超です
すげーの皆さんどうですか勉強安住さん勉強どうやってますかとか
ず原理勉強できません助けてくださいとかよく来るんですけど
ああ
頑張ってください東京都高校とか中学とか全然勉強しなかったねー
バカなんですよ僕
知ってると思うんですけどバカなりに勉強して
ま一応大学に行くくらい
勉強したつもりなんですけど何もない日は2時間以上は確実にしてたんで
ほんとねー
勉強嫌いだったんですけど
頭いようがかっこいいと思ったんで高校三年生から学校で順位が張り出さに何かそう
テストとかでも順位が張り出しにあって得意な英語時はああっ
できるだけ常に1位でも
なにこの順位表を見ても一番上に俺が乗ってるからなんかみたいな子なんか
カッコ基礎はまた i isuka 上みたいな
そういう感じで頑張ってましたねそういう感じでなかなか勉強に集中できないってくる
んですけど僕が勝手に編み出した勉強法を
教えてあげましょう
これから寒くなってくると風が風邪引きやすくなったり
イーグル円座も毎年のように流行ったりして体調管理はすごい図研製の方は気をつけ
ないといけないんですけど
まあ皆さんよくマスクしますよね
ぽけもよくするんですけど
2件2はもうマスクして勉強してください僕はずっとますキス勉強してたんですけど
マスクしたら集中力よ僕の時上がったんですよ
安寧かというと
マスクしてたなぁ
えっちょっとでもこれ言ったらまた何かあっ
そんなことないとか言われるけどこれ本当なんちょっと聞いてください
何かをペイする人ってみんなマースクしてますねこうやって
指定書
してないの自分が王ぺする人と思って勉強しました
意味わかんないとも言わないでペイする人って集中力あるじゃないですか知らないん
ですけど
なぜ猛勉強がオペみたいな感じで
加工
何机に向かってもいい
くっ集中して
何だろう
なんかもこれしかしないみたいな境内も電源切ってますねずっと
もう10時間ぐらいマスクつけてもちょっと
何かあった
呼吸が荒くなってもっ
医者になったつもりで勉強したら多分主事よく買われ
思いますた早く知らない女しか入っ
っていうことでぜひ集中できない人自分はう
手術
をする
医師のつもりになって
マスクして
勉強してみてください
持っています
そんなんでいいんかなぁ
なんか試したらわかると思うマスク作る時だけ勉強しかしないみたいなそういうなんか
オンとオフの切り替えをしっかりすれば
延長できると思います
だけど受験生の皆さん頑張って下さいねじゃあな